joe's a perfect fit for us and the fact
that uh you know he's a winner he's
played in a lot of big games
he has a lot of good football left in
him at 34 years old feel like he's just
uh
really coming into his prime so we're
excited the fact that uh he's going to
be our quarterback and think that like i
said he's a perfect fit for us
that's john elway the gm of the denver
broncos back when they signed joe flacco
now on his second team after a decade in
the nfl and that inspires today's draft
because flacco is going to start his his
first preseason game with the broncos he
sat out the hall of fame game will he be
better with the broncos than he was with
the ravens it's a high bar because he
won a super bowl and a super bowl mvp
award but chris today's draft
players who were better with their
second
teams and
surprisingly
it's a long list i i did the research on
this one baby i'm ready go ahead rig
coin toss it works on the road as well
make your call and then you get your
first pick
well kristen's feeling sorry for you
still go heads here kristen i'm heads
all the way because yeah i mean i'm on
fire with this thing i hope it continues
see i knew it she likes you
she likes you more than me and she's
trying to set it up for you but i'm
recognizing that i'm self-scouting the
situation right and i'm all over it so
here we go first pick easy one for me
right here drew brees okay talk about
stints that were better from you know
first team to the second team okay not
like the chargers were bad okay but he
never went to the playoffs with the san
diego chargers drew brees did some good
things there of course tore his shoulder
up uh
when playing for them in that last game
of the year uh that one season also they
they replaced them and drafted philip
rivers to replace drew brees and that's
why he became a free agent but come on
what he did with the second team
it's all-time greatness i mean he's only
thrown for 74 000 freaking yards and a
million touchdowns or whatever else but
the run he's had with the new orleans
saints and sean payton the offensive
numbers he's put up you know the the
amount of games they've won of course
winning a super bowl uh i i'd say that's
got to be one of the the the best ones
out there as far as players with their
second team
yeah you know i don't disagree with that
in theory but as the first pick it's a
little uninspired chris because he was a
four-year starter with the then san
diego chargers he had 3 500 passing
yards the last season he was in san
diego before he was allowed to leave in
free agency when philip rivers was ready
to go i mean if you want a dramatic
difference from first team to second
team you had the right position but
you got to go with brett favre
drafted by the atlanta falcons in 1991
didn't play at all
gets traded to green bay packers becomes
one of the all-time great quarterbacks
in nfl history the all-time great iron
man started all those games in a row and
uh and so synonymous with the packers
you don't even think that he played for
the atlanta falcons when you're that
good with your second team that most
people even forget there was a first
team that is a much better performance
with your second team than your first
team so my first pick which should have
been your first pick brett favre
well he was only there for a year he was
on the bench uh i i thought about brett
favre going on honestly mike did not
think you would pick him or were you
smart enough to pick that one up i
thought you would be one of those people
that you mentioned that would forget
about his first team i was betting after
two years after two years together that
really hurts did you think i wouldn't
think of brett favre
i know it does hurt but i like to kick
you when you're down okay um
all right man there's so many to pick
from here i don't know which one's best
but i'm gonna go with this one okay
because this like you said the stint
with the first team was so uninspiring
and underwhelming i'm gonna go with
chris carter okay chris carter going
from the philadelphia eagles having all
these off the field issues really doing
nothing special on the field at the time
he had in 1989 his third year in the nfl
had 605
yards that was his best season with the
eagles oh and then he just goes on to
the minnesota vikings and catches 12 300
yards there and a whole bunch of 110
touchdowns all he does is catch
touchdowns that happened on his second
team so chris carter when i look about a
guy transforming from team one to team
two i mean he went from a guy to where
we thought he might be on the streets at
some point leaving philadelphia and who
knows what's gonna happen to his life to
being not only awesome football player
with the minnesota vikings but
straightening out his life and of course
going into the great tv career and doing
all that so that to me was one of the
biggest transformations i've ever seen
from one team to the next
he did have 11 touchdown catches in his
last year with the eagles and it took
you shut up
six years to beat that
now six years to beat that all right
that that one's not bad and again i i
think that the true greatness with that
second team makes you forget that the
player ever played with that first team
the player becomes synonymous with the
second team i'm going to slide over to
the running back position a hall of
famer who as you may know is from
detroit jerome bettis pittsburgh steeler
through and through well yeah but he
also was a member of the rams for three
seasons before he became a member of the
steelers and he was so good with the
steelers for so many years we forget
that he did have a good stint with the
rams not not eric dickerson level with
the rams but he had 1429 yards as a
rookie but he ended up with pittsburgh
in
1996 and never looked back 10 years with
the steelers one of the all-time great
running backs in steelers history and uh
far better with his second team than he
was with his first team
well no there's no doubt about that he
was on my short list as well i i hear
you there i mean but but again he falls
in line where it wasn't bad with the
rams i'm gonna like try to downplay your
pick since you do it to every one of
mine uh but either way yes we know him
as a steeler he gave that team attitude
the bus the power physical running game
uh so i understand that he was on my
list as well
oh man i don't know where i go with this
last one i'm i'm like truly trying to
figure out there's too many people but i
think this is pretty easy okay
i'm gonna go with old laissez-faire
steve young okay
[Music]
that's my man steve i'm not mad at you
for calling me las vega we're over that
we're bigger people we're lefties we got
to stick together there's so few of us
out there but yes i mean i gotta go if
i'm gonna be real to this draft steve
young and you know coming from the tampa
bay buccaneers i mean he couldn't even
throw a pass when he was there it just
it wasn't right it certainly was
underwhelming bill walsh and company saw
something in steve young's game to where
they wanted him in san francisco and
thought they could work on them and uh
bill walsh was right because he got him
there uh he got coached by mike holmgren
as an offensive coordinator and went to
a number of nfc championship games one
mvps in the nfl and of course won the
super bowl and a super bowl mvp uh
throwing six touchdown passes in that
performance against the san diego
chargers so that to me uh really maybe
maybe this should have been the first
pick i mean this could have been the
first pick i i i when you really look at
it because nothing special in tampa 2200
yards one year eight touchdowns 13
interceptions 900 yards another year
three touchdowns eight interceptions but
then he goes to san francisco and of
course throws for 24 000 yards while
he's there and throws her 221 touchdowns
uh an amazing career with his second
team steve young my third pick that
should nail the cough and i win this
draft and for those of you who didn't
get the reference steve young never
called chris sims laissez-faire what
steve young said back in 2005 or
thereabouts is that chris wasn't a very
good nfl quarterback because he had a
laissez-faire upbringing which was a
misapplication of the term for a guy who
supposedly is highly intelligent but the
point was growing up in the phil sims
household you had it a little bit easy
because you had money and because you
had fame little did steve young know
that he was going to walk right into the
right hand of phil sims for questioning
the the overall uh
the parenting skills of a guy who
probably was not nearly as easy on you
as steve young would think
no no they don't know the big effort if
they uh
big phil was sitting there making life
easy you know again my dad was the the
son of a farmer uh and my mom was the
daughter of a butcher so uh that's not
like we're old money and doing all that
but all good i
seriously uh really enjoy steve young
when i see him and i've told you a
million times before he apologizes to me
it's the first thing he says to me every
time he sees me and he doesn't need to
do that but uh either way hall of fame
quarterback awesome
player well and and uh i i've got one
more and there are three or four that
i'm trying to whittle down here and i'm
gonna cut it down to two who were
members of the same phenomenal team the
greatest show-offs on turf i mean the
greatest show on turf from 1999 through
2001 really the height of their powers i
could go marshall falk but you know what
he was pretty good with the indianapolis
colts he had a 2 000 yards from
scrimmage season with the colts so he
was no slouch there but there's another
guy your friend in mind hall of fame
quarterback kurt warner he was a member
of the green bay packers in 1994 before
he went on his meanderings through the
arena football league and bagging
groceries at the piggly wiggly before
landing out of the blue
in saint louis as the starting
quarterback after trent greene had his
knee imploded accidentally by rodney
harrison in a preseason game
kurt warner not to mention the
preeminent quarterback ranker in today's
media the oh that's a second
oreo shut up
second team
uh uh uh
you got me all flustered now but that
was just for you i know warner second
team so much better than with his first
team i also thought about john united
same idea steelers cut him he never
played for the steelers he was on the
team they cut him and he goes to be one
of the all-time greats but i'll go with
kurt warner just for you you went with
steve young just for you i'll go with
kurt warner just for you
thank you very much but hey kurt warner
that success story is one of the
greatest in the history of the nfl
there's no denying that i believe that
my quarterback ranking skills will
prevail okay by the time this season's
over and we'll see who's better at that
but he sure the hell was damn better on
the football field than me and it was
awesome i was there at the super bowl
when they beat the tennessee titans uh
it was a phenomenal game great finish
but i'm with you mike i mean that's hard
to argue there with kurt warner hey the
other one the other thing uh you know
who is some other names i mean champ
bailey i thought about throwing him out
there marshawn lynch okay he was another
one that i thought about a little bit um
and i guess that's the end of my big
names there and then you mentioned
johnny united i did have him on my list
as well
you know i had khalil mack but it's such
a limited sample size but the impact he
had on the bears last season felt like
bigger than anything he did during his
years with the raiders and also terrell
owens what that first year in
philadelphia was
phenomenal off the charts what he did
for that offense he was he was very good
in san francisco but for that limited
slice in philadelphia we've never seen
anything like terrell owens so i thought
about him as well you know back to kurt
warner it's been like five or six years
since i saw a story that that they had
optioned his life story for making into
a movie when are they gonna make that
damn movie because if there should be a
movie about anyone that ever played in
the nfl that's the ultimate story forget
about rudy oh no that was a college
thing or invincible to vince papali make
the kurt warner movie for crying out
loud all right chris has drew brees
chris carter steve young i've got brett
favre jerome bettis kurt warner we'll
get your feedback on social media chris
i you think you won this one i i like my
picks too so we'll see what the people
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports